- I'm going to try celebrity impressions.
- [Guy] Who's that?
- I don't know (beep) know.
(swing music)
- I feel like I can do a few
celebrity impersonations.
- I never ever, ever want to
be the person, who's just like,
"You've got to hear my so and so"
- If you act like you know
what you're doing then other
people think they, you
know what you're doing.
- I've never seen any of
these papers with the names
written down, so I'm just
going to pick one out and
we're going to go for it.
- It's Leviosa, not Leviosar!
- Wow. That's all I got.
- Ehhhalll!
- I am the Governor of California.
- I guess it's just a lot of talking.
- I just feel like California
needs to change, how we
elect our government.
Did you like that?
Because it's like though
I never knew Arnold
Schwarzenegger was ever an actor.
- I'd like to drink some tea
while reading the newspaper.
Oh, that's horrible!
- It seems to be a very green day.
- Well, it's not easy being green.
- It's not easy being green. Now.
(laughing)
- I'm a frog!
- Oh yelling. Bounce!
- What do you mean you've
got me doing impressions in
this room?
There's a couple out here drinking water.
They tell you to drink eight cups a day.
No one drinks eight cups a day.
- What's the deal with taxi cabs?
This is Seinfeld, Christopher Walken!
- I'm the king of the north!
- Ohhh....
- I've seen the north wall.
- We are all brothers of the night watch.
(stabbing noises)
- Will! Where's my son? Will!
- Will! Has anybody seen my son?
- Will are you there?
- Where's my boy?
I want to find my boy.
- Hopper, where is he?
He's in the lights.
- Will! Will! Nailed it.
- Finger boy...oh fuck I
can't even do it anymore.
I need to practice.
- Shampoo is better, I go
on first and clean the hair.
No, conditioner is better.
I leave the hair silky and smooth.
- Finger boy , oh yeah finger boy!
- You call this fucking
scrambled eggs there.
I told you to make fucking
scrambled eggs and you
act like a fucking god
damn idiot over there.
- You did a bad job cooking!
- It is going to be Yuge!
- Huge!
- Huuuge!
- It's going to be huge.
That wasn't even close to
what he sounds like at all.
- I love bread.
- You get a car! You get
a car! You get a car!
- Ohhh Myyy Gooddd.
It's fucking Oprah.
- No, no, no, no, no. What are you doing?
- (breathing loudly)
- You tell me! What are you doing?
- Uh huh huh
- Uh huh, Uh huh, yeah babe.
That was like Mick Jagger.
- I can do like Russian Elvis.
Oh pa chee dega dee. Ba dega dee.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- I think that on a scale from
1-10, I was a very solid 2.5.
- I just like made a lot of weird noises.
I hope people in the office
couldn't hear me through
the walls.
They probably think something
is wrong, and they are
going to call the police.
- Thank you!
(laughing)
- You've ruined my day.
I feel terrible.
- That was really awkward.
( tuba music)
- Yo, Adrienne! I did it!